to find the treble clef i started by
going to the musical symbol section
because well that just makes sense
looking through all the characters it
looks like there is a treble clef right
there and voila there is its html code
right here for easy copy and pasting i'm
testing out the treble clef by pasting
its html code here and then observing
what happens on the site over here and
notice there's the treble clef so
clearly this html code is working by the
way this is just the same koala website
you saw a few minutes ago this looks
good
but
i wonder what would happen if i just
simply pasted the treble clef itself
into the html remember it's just a
normal character so i will copy it
and i will paste it right here
now look
i've got the treble clef over here in
the html and i've got the treble clef in
the site this is nice because these two
match
in fact it's actually recommended to
copy and paste the actual unicode
character into your html it's easier to
read and maintain
so the correct answer is
ampersand pound sign and then the number
that you see here that's the html code
for treble clef